On the night 11, zoom call you answered someone that they might want to get a mastectomy,
which surprised me because initially you said you didn't believe in reconstructive
surgery.
I know that's two different things, but isn't it true that cutting into cancer may spread
it?
So let's answer that question.
So it surprises you that I may suggest someone do a mastectomy, a lumpectomy, or chemotherapy
or immunotherapy.
I don't, I mean, you haven't listened to me for very long because I, and I try to be
insulted, but I'm just trying to say that I am very open minded to what's best for each
person.
So it's everybody's an individual, and I think it's wrong and I've said this maybe 5,000
times to, I think it's very wrong to take a dogmatic stance on things like this.
There's things that you take a dogmatic stance on, but health care things, mostly you have
to be open minded.
So I'm not against doing a mastectomy, if that's the right thing for that person.
I know some people that they're just will not do it, because it's not right for them,
but I also know some people that won't do it because they're so domatically positioned
or angry against the medical field for some reason that that's a necessarily healthy eater.
We have to be open minded to, hey, is maybe it's time to debug a cancer.
So can surgery increase growth factors?
Yes.
Surgery of any kind can increase growth factor.
But I say I'm against reconstructive surgery.
It's because that's a very elective surgery.
Now, again, I'm only against it in principle.
I know there's a lot of women that will have their breast removed, but they'll have reconstructive
therapy because also emotionally tied to having a breast, and I understand, I can't fully
understand it.
I'm not a woman, but I can understand that your emotions are equally as important in your
health recovery as anything else.
You are a whole person.
Some other women will be forgetting, I'm getting a removed eye, you know, and that's probably
healthier.
Not doing elective surgeries that will increase growth factors is probably a smarter idea.
But everybody's got to weigh that out as well.
As far as a mastectomy, you're debulking a tumor, so I have never been against debulking
a tumor.
Now, that is surgery and it's going to increase growth factor, but there's a huge benefit
to debulking a tumor.
So if you have a giant mast in your colon, number one, it could block the lumen and cause
backup and emergency surgery situation.
But just debulking it decreases the amount of energy that your immune system needs to expand
to kill the cancer.
So if I have a three centimeter round mast in my breast, develop an energy that my immune system
has to put out to try to kill all those cells and to stop that growth is tremendous.
If that could be removed, now my immune system could maybe expand its energy on circulating
tumor cells and, you know, these cancer stem cells and where there could be metastasis
and not be is involved with dealing with this mess.
So it can be very beneficial to debulking a cancer.
Of course, there's risks, especially brain surgery and things like that.
And there's times when it's not important to do that, but everybody's different.
Every case is different.
To shut this question, I have a breast that is slowly over one and a half years being
eaten away with a huge disgusting scam on it.
When I asked the oncologist about it, they said it would continue to eat away.
Well, that's his, that's a person's one person's opinion.
It could certainly stop too.
Does this mean I need to have surgery to remove it?
Not necessarily we have patients that it eats away and it just stops and they end up with
a scam and they still live 10 years later.
So everybody's different.
So you have to weigh all those things out.
So you weigh out everybody's opinion.
This doctor obviously thinks that you should do a mastectomy, I think probably.
I would say if that's an option from a surgeon's standpoint, that is an option for you.
But just debulking a cancer, remember, doesn't remove, doesn't mean you've removed all
the cancer stem cells.
It means absolutely doesn't mean you've removed all the cancer stem cells or circulated
tumor cells.
So it doesn't mean that you've completely solved your problem.
So if I have a little lump in my breast and I go and I remove both my breasts, doesn't mean
no, I don't have breast cancer anymore.
Well, you know, it means that you debolt that breast cancer.
You certainly have circulated tumor cells in your body long before you ever discovered
that you had cancer.
So while it was still two million cells, large, it was giving off circulated tumor cells and
it was not even discoverable at that size.
So it's not that you're solving your problem completely, but you're debulking a mast that
would be the advantage of doing surgery.
But again, I'm not saying everybody has to do surgery.
We have lots of patients that have never done surgery on their cancers.
And they're still going today.
So everybody is different.
Will it continue to eat away by body or eventually stop?
Well, nobody can honestly answer that question, because nobody knows the future.
So the oncologist is giving his opinion, has he ever seen anybody that has not done what
he asked to do, which is surgery, and that would be a question that you could ask that
oncologist.
I don't know if they'll give you an honest answer.
We've seen people not get surgery and it stopped eating away and it stops and they're still
alive today.
We've seen people, it didn't stop and they ended up passing away.
We've had people get mastectomies and pass away and have mastectomies and live along
happy life.
It's just, you can't say one way or the other, you can't say dogmaticly, everybody needs
to do this or everybody needs to do that, you can't do that.
You can, but you'd be lying, that's just not honest.
So I refuse to not be honest just to play Kate, people, or to push my agenda.
I think that's just wrong.
I don't put anything topically on it's comfortable, wear a fake breast on top of it because it
oozes your cerebellum at times which I think is good because you're getting out dead
cells that way.
I know you're going to say that it's up to me, but I really don't want to have surgery.
Okay, well, you know, again, I think you need to just like everything else in our life.
We need to pray about it with an open mind and your prayer should be something like Lord,
I don't, you know, I don't want to do surgery, but if you want me to do surgery, I'm open
to your will be done.
So change my heart, change my mind, change my heart of this.
There's no Bible verse.
It says thou shalt not do surgery, though there is one saying thou shalt do surgery when the surgeon
tells you you should do surgery and they are God and you need to do what they tell you to
do.
There's nothing on it.
It's dependent upon our relationship with him to know what to do in certain situations.
We can't have all our answers in black and white and there's a reason, oh, I wish I could
have done it.
I wish it was just all right.
No, what to do?
No, you don't.
Then you would need a relationship with the living God.
You're worth to have a relationship with the living God and he knows our hearts and but to
speak to him that way, God, I do not want to have surgery.
I know I do not want to have surgery, but if you want me to have surgery and this is what
you want me to do to save my life or for whatever reason, then I'll be open to it.
Change my heart, change my mind, you know, work on my heart, I'll be open to it.
That's how I pray for these things and how I'd suggest you to do so too.